okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about
biological sequence processing and wolf
language and we have both a bunch of
internal folk and some outside experts
who I hope will help us and me
understand what is going on here so what
is the basic idea so the basic idea oh
boy that's a lot of functions to do with
bio sequences really if you had say the
last time the human genome is never all
change substantive you might really have
24 into deficit oh God
you took me literally yes I mean you
know usually in a lot of these things
we're trying to have sort of named um
you know string named properties and
things like that rather than so many
explicit functions all right but okay so
let's just get some sense of what this
is so bio sequence representing so
essentially these are long stringy
molecules of the various kinds of
biology chooses to use is that that's
right
okay and so what is a sequence molecule
different from a bio sequence that's
something which is the molecule
representation of a bio sequence that's
right the [ __ ] that's the function that
takes it by our sequence and we'll
return a molecule with the appropriate
end caps and so there is a in a sense
you should also be able to take a
molecule and it's like recognizing I
mean you know a particular pattern of
molecule should be recognizable as a bio
sequence of a particular kind that's a
that's a harder job than going the other
obviously right so you haven't got that
set up yet right but okay that that's
like digesting you know here's all the
atoms in a lump of RNA tell us what the
RNA sequence specification for that
should be um okay this seems like a
excessive number of functions but okay
let me just understand what um okay so I
see so things like um things like this
and then blast like things is it the
case that there's a version of
similarity that is different depending
on what biomolecule we're looking at
that's right
depending on what kind of thought mile
molecule there is they can have
different g-general terms and therefore
different similarity calculations so
just so I understand in in um and this
is a question maybe maybe Trevor or
somebody knows knows this the you know
blast and things like that are a
reflection of the physical propensity of
different bases to change or are they
something that reflects the historical
likelihood of bases changing in in the
way that you know DNA is actually used
by biology so that kind of matrix matrix
ladies that will rely and like looking
at you have evolution that's happened
and things have their urge from one
another but you know it used to be the
same thing and so kind of encoded in how
much similarity there is is both some
process of how transversion transition
kind of bias so some more mutations will
happen more often than others but also
kind of amino acid similarities so that
some amino acids will substitute more
easily for other amino acids and will be
rejected by natural selection but so
when when we have a bio sequence and
it's a it's a piece of RNA for example
do we have to know something about this
RNA was in you know I don't know
I don't even know if they have it on
archaea versus this RNA was in a
something else to know what to correct
similarity it's a good question so so if
you wanted kind of an optimal alignment
you would probably want to know about
that main like the one the most
important parameter for RNA would be
this transition translation ratio AG
versus ET and that would that you could
if you have like a long enough string
you could learn that yourself
or you could kind of have some some
simple kind of default that would more
or less work for that it's not going to
be hugely mattering but it will never
feel like you can imagine a little
segment that is like hayes and genes
versus ease and T's that you might align
it slightly differently um if you prefer
if you think that ace and G's mutate
together more often
good you take one another more often
okay so bottom line there is that
probably needs to be some prominence
annotation for bio sequence to help or
some at least metadata for bio sequence
to help with things like this is that
yes I know it seems really hard having a
lookup table like an you're okay or
bacteria are enough yeah okay
okay so this is gonna be a can of worms
this whole business about whether we
that now I mean there must be some very
naive things here like the translation
from I mean um and this is stretching my
pathetic biology knowledge but I mean
you know the the very you know like like
the various some translations from RNA
to proteins and the you know the the you
case for and again I'm I'm gonna
embarrass myself with my biology
knowledge but they you know when there's
a you instead of a tea and things like
this so presumably we do we have some
functions here oh I see we do say
there's no baby examples of reason to
the depths in each of the sections it
was just for the very cream okay okay
fine all right how much of this actually
exists by the way Jose everything that's
in black exists in the prototype build
so everything except for the finding the
gene positions and genes and snips
exists in the build the the finding does
exist but it's waiting on integration
into our infrastructure that kind of fun
ok so then um okay and this is using the
standard conventions for what these what
w's and things like that mean in turn
right unknown uh you know undetermined
between different bases type thing okay
cool okay so if I type this in I mean so
if I if I just say random choice you
know let's be a I don't know I think
these are crabs do this don't they well
they have a lot of them if I just say
this and I say string join does it work
for the for the list of symbols as well
probably should the bio sequence can
take a list as well as taking the as
well as taking a string I think it does
just take the string right now but I'll
make it take the West for sure
okay why is it oh I see it didn't it
doesn't like that because I didn't tell
it what he needed type okay that should
be better better error messages rather
than just sitting there for a long time
and being confused okay
okay all right fine okay what can i well
I'm probably gonna ask him that what I
can do with this okay okay and RNA
I mean I said I assume that these are
all totally standardized at this point
that's right
yes I mean we support the standard ones
and the discussion of whether we want to
override types for potential topic for
this session but I mean like like
somebody who's building their own
synthetic biology that has some funky
you know I don't know what germanium
based life-form or something no those
don't exist but but you know a funky
amino acid is there some standard way of
representing that and one of these
strings generally now generally it's
limited to the biology folk on this call
I mean like for example for us could we
do it by like having a - there and then
having some key or something I don't
know how it would work I mean or or
having some unicode character there that
represents something different or
insisting that if it's non-standard
amino acids that this thing be a list
rather than a rather than a string and
then being able to put some symbolic
object in there like like a whole
molecule for example I mean I suppose
that would be the most obvious way to do
this right if it is to insist that this
be a list to explode this into a list
and then to have just a single character
G or something there so just be a happy
ordinary amino acid but then in general
in worst case to have an actual symbolic
molecule object there to represent um
kind of you know an arbitrary amino acid
is that crazy
Stephen we have something similar where
we do have to deal with conjugates
between bio sequences of like it's an
amino acid connected to a piece of DNA
and sometimes there's something
synthetic in the middle like a weird
like remnant from a quick conjugation or
something like that so we actually ended
up creating like a slop thing that was
bio sequence bars of a sequence but it
was like one modification or something
yeah modifications you can just kind of
put whatever you want that you defined
to be custom in there I give you a floor
for at the end of a piece of like DNA
just it's a little bit like the
user-defined unit thing like that yeah
like an independent unit kind of thing
yeah I see so okay but so so that then
in this bio sequence what you're saying
is it is convenient to
ah I mean if we made this into a list of
just string characters followed by some
symbolic thing that represents the weird
thingy that's hanging off the end but
that would be a reasonable way to do it
it's what your is what is that what
you're saying and that would be somewhat
consistent with what you have built is
that a true statement or is that far
away that or some larger wrapper around
a like a list of bio sequences that say
these guys are all in a line that's how
we solved it we have like a conjugate we
call like a strand yeah and then there's
a strand is a series of sequences which
can include these weird chemical
modifications that are unnatural so then
you might have bio sequence okay so
let's say that bio sequence was a thing
that could be nested so it's bio
sequence of bio sequences um I think
that's a if you do allowed us okay but
but okay so then so then what it might
be is an amino acid followed by some
weird you know piece of glue followed by
another amino acid is that the idea or a
piece of DNA yeah exactly
yeah for me my level of the stuff it's
okay
all right so find
okay so find a snip that's a very weird
return that's very weird yeah I so what
I guess what it's saying is that the 569
position you can find well aware and
well aware but none of our other
functions that find positions of things
work that way I mean sequence position
for example would find
I mean what sequence position would do
is to return the starting and ending
coordinates um let me understand
something in in the world of slippery I
mean whenever I play around with my own
genome and I want to find some
particular snip in my genome I do the
incredible in the and earth all thing if
I find flanking sequences and he just
goes search for those literal flanking
sequences in my genome because that way
I don't think I'm gonna get it wrong
where the snip position is what I mean
what is the official definition of one
of these snip positions does that make
sense as a question I mean maybe
somebody that's just maybe Trevor or the
emerald folk have have a comment on this
did did my question make sense
yeah I don't know these are s number
human genetics I know if I was doing
this within bacterial or viral I would
need a basically it always relies on a
reference genome Evan you're it's like
it's position 500 in this reference you
know and you have to have reference I
see and so then once you've got that so
then the the analog of a snip positioned
for you is with respect to this
reference sequence it's positioned
twenty thousand or something in this
reference sequence when you go when you
go line it up then you know that they'll
you know that there'll be many changes
from the reference sequence and then you
actually have to have code that goes in
and finds flanking sequences and things
to try and line up what happens if it
doesn't what happens if it's
undetermined I mean so in other words in
practical terms if there are multiple
places you know if the thing is a mess
and has bunch of repeats in it what
actually what what typically is done
people throw up their hands
you know have a definitive alignment
okay the way that this one works is if
it finds the best available position
against the reference and then against
the a fairly broad nearby region takes
the alignment between the given sequence
in the reference sequence and then we'll
search for the snip difference kind of
where it's supposed to be given the
corrections from that alignment wait a
second so okay so hold on so you have an
algorithm that basically says given I
mean this snip you could go look up in
the reference human genome and you could
know it's flanking stuff and so on I
have no idea what happens as you go
between two different reference
sequences and things like that it's hard
but the way I handled that case was I
would look to buy it for nearby genes
between different
Jeannot Jeannot McGill's and use that to
we're kind of recalibrate where the
sequence okay but I mean this can really
matter like I mean you know you
absolutely cannot get this wrong right
right so I mean this is going to be you
know big deal for for okay so actually
emerald folk have you have you had this
issue as well or not so we don't do a
lot of bioinformatics right now we're
mostly useful because we do buy organic
chemistry so previous section we do a
ton of not a lot of this so okay fair
enough so yeah okay all right um
the okay so I understand I'm a little
scared of what you're saying John and I
think we need to look at that very
carefully because we really don't want
to make a mistake I mean much better to
say we can't find this snip than to say
no it's here you know you've got a T for
that value and then it turns out that
the person's genome is actually a mess
and they don't really have a T there
that makes sense we should review ever
really great testing for this and review
for sure um okay I'm also not thrilled
about the return value here and I don't
really like this but let's see some more
before you come back to this and I
understand I think this is the wrong way
round I think it's I mean this reminds
me of text cases for example have you
looked at the design of text cases I
mean in other words in text position for
example let me start up let me not tempt
fate let me use them um let me use a
12.0 here
so in text position we've got a similar
kind of thing find okay so in text
position what we might do yeah there we
go so this is we've got various
annotations for how to present what you
find right um the star
position the string identified etc so I
could imagine the string identified is
what you want here you got what I'm
saying so in other words yes you say
this snip what is it in this case
alright um so I think it's
have a design more like you know a bio
sequence position or something or
something like that
than right then but let's do a light
look through all of this stuff and then
we'll come back and and and get into
more details probably a different a
different time here okay so because yeah
I would like to know what is at that
position you know and this snip I mean
are all the RS snips single positions
are they all single you know not all of
them are what a mess what else are they
I mean they're they can they can they
can be longer and there can also be kind
of multiple variants identified per so
it's kind of one standard of arbitrary
length and then the multiple variants
that are associated with it
oh yeah but if we look at the properties
of that snip for example we will be able
to find out in general you know what you
know what the different I don't know
what they were we can out what is the
property called
that um you know what I'm asking right
so what this is saying weighted allele
frequencies here this is not the world's
most lovely representation of that I
have to say um okay so that's just
showing cuz that's what we're typically
gonna want right I mean given what what
it's gonna want to say is okay in this
particular bio sequence the result was
an a there yes there's also a later an
alignment view that shows this detail
okay fine all right so let's take a look
at alright to find the locations and the
corresponding two genes Wow
now isn't that kind of complicated in
general or as that is that now
considered to solve problem I mean if I
throw you an arbitrary random you know
you know RNA of some random virus is it
even again by Austrian I don't know the
answer is it even well-defined where the
genes are only if you have I'm assuming
here you have a lookup table of like you
have all of these hemoglobin sequences
and you you're using black or something
like it to do a very fast alignment or
they're not even real alignment very
fast kind of seeding sort of line knows
to be able to say yes these are
identical I don't know what happens if
you have some minor variation and like
then like clean start to stretch of it
where if you have diversity maybe it's
already kind of make that makes that
call okay but I mean isn't it I mean
naively a gene is sort of a thing you
know a piece of the sequence that gets
transcribed and turns into something
mm-hmm and but if I understand I mean it
used to be the case I know whether this
is a solved problem I like fifteen
twenty years ago it used to be like
whether the genes start and stop yes so
so this yeah so this will behind that
gene
behind you book open cell alpha-1
subunit not the one you'll have all of
these different forms these like
different slicing forms and so forth so
like one gene might have a like a locus
in the genome but they'll have a whole
bunch of different RNAs that are
associated that are kind of created by
that gene which creates a bunch of
different proteins that are different
kind of splicing variants and so forth
so there is yeah there's definitely
complexity there okay but there's a
different thing that we could ask for
here from this you know bio sequence
features which is use some heuristic to
decide where you know I don't know
coding sequences or something start and
stop on this but like for example can I
ask where are the coding sequences on
this bio sequence it's a reasonable
question it's not it's not in this
implementation but that's a reasonable
thing to ask but isn't it I mean that's
a sort of machine learning type question
isn't it I mean there's not a precise
answer to that
no true statement yeah yeah there's a
distinction between the ones that are
known and the ones that we could
potentially determine for something like
it yeah right that's right
no I mean it is my vague impression that
the state of the art is quite decent on
determining where those things are is
that a true statement or or not I
believe so so all of the encode data has
done a bunch here you do have
alternative start sites that often
person that's like there is the rule and
then there's the exception of the rule
but you can actually figure out what
what what letters that were upstream of
the promoter caused cause this exception
to occur and so so you might need more
context then that would be provided by
just the bio sequence like if if you
were missing kind of the stuff that's a
bit upstream you might not be able to
make the easy call for example I don't
know okay so what we're seeing here what
on earth is this in this entity instance
this reference sequence based pairs so
that that's saying these positions in
this particular bio sequence are this
sub part of the hemoglobin sub unit
alpha one that's right all right yes
yowee okay okay I guess biology is kind
of complicated it's what happens after a
couple billion years
okay and what are we seeing okay well I
think we should keep going and just do a
quick scan through everything here okay
what on earth is this so this is showing
slips and alignment right so this shows
where in the alignment the sniffs the
snips are found but this isn't alignment
what how did it how did it end up with
two sequences here oh it's this thing is
saying that there were two sequences and
it's got a comparison there was a TN one
to see in the other right yes
it's it's the one provided the one
provided is the first and the second is
the reference sequence
how does it know what it's a referent I
mean how does it know if is the horse or
or an elephant I mean human is assumed
throughout so this is all been this is
all been human
but why okay but I mean that doesn't
seem self-evident but that's what we
should do in other words wait a second
so the snips obviously are human snips
right so I mean we can imagine some kind
of you know dollar default organism or
something right and you know when the
Apes take over they can change the
default default organism I'm sorry it
but but but nevertheless in a case like
this
understand why your oh I see alignment
is another thing is that a third
argument or is that a third argument
that says what to display in the output
find the snips and display it as an
alignment okay so okay the third
argument is the result format so that's
that's similar to the thing that I was
complaining about with them
with text position or the right way it
works is to use a rule to specify you
know it would say snips arrow alignment
in the way that text position works for
what it's worth that's a good convention
yeah well we should come back to this
I'm not sure it's the right thing for
this um okay cool
okay classification properties yes a
quick question about the at the bottom
level is there a way to handle
degeneracy in the sequences in the bio
sequences themselves to say that this
position is like a Y or something we saw
earlier yeah absolutely all the
degenerate bases are built in and
there's a fair number of functions for
processing degenerate bases that is it's
also one reason why we have a different
sequence alignment is to support the
generate base matching okay thanks okay
oh I see so wait a minute so sequence
alignment has been generalized to deal
with degenerate basis is that correct
that's right or if you in this Illumina
lardy rules option there's now a using
views degenerate basis value they can
identify them okay all right what's all
this stuff here so this is similar to
classify and the problem is is that a
trevor was telling me that frequently
you don't only want to know what the
potentially the best match for position
is you want to see all of the likely
matches but by for a position you mean I
don't understand what that means so
given the mutations that might might
might occur it's it could be that this
is the sequence you provide it could be
mapped to multiple standard positions on
the genome and and so in order to not
just see the best one but to see all
potential results we've exposed that
under those underlying probabilities in
the same way that
to fight us okay I make sense to me I
mean this looks like kind of a mess I
mean the way that the way we're
specifying this position on the genome I
think we're gonna need a wrapper for
that I think this is an you know that
that seems to I mean really what that is
is essentially a a what is it it's like
a bio sequence location or something I
mean it's analogous to you know it's the
analog of geo position I suppose that's
good not really because here we have an
entity and then we take a sub part of it
the CEO position we don't have a third
entity for earth we don't want a cube
position relative to a continent okay
let me let me let me try and counter
that I mean so geo position with the geo
model our own moon is certainly
referencing you know it's lat/long is
very different from the lat/long on the
earth I don't quite get this I mean
you're saying my point is that geo
position admittedly it's real numbers
instead of integer positions is
something where it is relative to an
existing object we're saying what
position are you at right and this I
mean okay I understand this the Strand
specifier I mean this is saying on the
earth that's chromosome five or on on
you know I don't know what you know
random asteroid Ceres um you know this
is that this is the location that we are
talking about on the asteroid Ceres I
mean in general what we would probably
want is something which is more like
species you know comma I mean this this
thing ultimately would be something that
is some kind of species chromosome okay
another biology question is it the case
okay let me let me just ask this some
this question uh okay is that a correct
specifier for a particular base pair in
any known living thing or is that not a
if a species specifier like like
presumably there's a you know like in in
NCBI
there are discrete species even when
they're viruses and bacteria is that a
true statement or is that not a is that
some designated there is an NCBI okay
people are give out the bidding and so
forth but they're at least okay so
there's a tax tax tax tax ID there no
that doesn't that's that's not okay
forget that
um but anyway there's something like
that then are there numbered chromosomes
for everything in the in the in the
known biological world or does that
works for things that have been kind of
yet described officially yes all the
chromosomes will be numbered although
like some things that will be Leonard
instead rather than numbered and of
chromosome H a and chromosome P and so
forth just things but each thing will
have official chromosome that we other
taxa that exists that goes and doesn't
have official chromosomes to it at that
point okay but so like MT for the magic
on drienne for the humans it's an
example and of a named chromosome rather
than a yes um and then the Strand that
always exists yeah cuz that's two
standard DNA
guys say okay um okay so I reckon that
we need a some kind of I mean maybe we
even I mean genomic position or
something something that is that has
takes things like this and where we can
say things like genomic position one
genomic position maybe even - another
genomic position I know whether that
makes sense but where we can do things
like say give us the bio sequence that
is that is sort of bounded by these two
genome ik positions is this at all
sensible yeah take a brief look at I
paste it into at some point there's a
concept of Eakins now that human
geneticists have been working on where
there
they're trying to because this this
isn't this isn't a novel problem and
everyone has this thing where like you
can't figure out if we're talking about
the same thing and so there's been work
on the human genetic side to try to help
me have this concept that you can
actually gather an agreement yes this
this this location is the same location
okay so in other words this is like so
in in the case of geo position we have
this notion of datums for the earth
because there are different like the
North American datum is different from
the GPS datum blah blah blah is that is
that is there going to end up being
something similar to that I mean that
there must be fast for the reference
sequences and things that's right it's a
very least we're gonna have to also
include a builder assembly yes okay fine
yes so so I'm I'm I'm taking seriously
this genomic position or whatever it is
um right I don't know if that's quite
the right name but but it's something
like that and then then that becomes you
know in a sense then it's uh you know
it's almost like Geographics where you
can say show me the stuff you know well
show me stuff right around that genomic
position would be probably a useful
thing I'm not sure exactly how that
works so there's also place a to
proteins yes so so you're saying by a
sequence position or I or position or
something um
so maybe May bio sequence position
and then it's got to have a specifier of
but but in a sense this is you know like
this is - this is saying you know you
can have a bio sequence that is
completely synthetic and just you know
random a random you know well you know
random molecule but this is grounding it
to a thing that evolution is actually
produced or that people have actually
identified with taxon IDs and things
like this so the first argument could be
an expert seed sequence then you can
sneak in whatever you want that's fair
yeah that's fair so I mean this needs
some work about what this should look
like okay fine so let's keep going here
so that would make this look a lot nicer
now I guess this business with positions
again I I think this should work the
same way as text position works okay we
got a lot to look at here so let's let's
let's just do a quick scan through all
of this um I unfortunately have a time
constraint in about 20 minutes or so um
the UM this is given what's found then
extract the sub sequences associated
with it I'm gonna make a meta point
about all this this is clearly a large
subsystem I think michael has already
made this point I mean this is this is
gonna be a lot of work it's gonna be
great but it's gonna be a lot of work um
okay
establish what is this should
protein entities result in list of bio
sequences so these are like proteins
like I don't know that assemble
themselves and little you know Penta
MERS and things all right or is that B
right were there emolia multiple
sequences really that make up the
protein right and where it has some kind
of self-assembly thingy or something
sure I mean I'm thinking like like the
the capsids of I I don't know if I know
what I'm talking about but I'm just
curious whether this is what you mean
like the like the the capsids of fire
viruses is that an example of something
like this
I'm hoping something like trouble will
help me here and how do those work that
those that those are many proteins right
that self-assemble into the actual shape
yes like there someplace okay and that's
what we're talking about here is having
that right or in other words when you
have a protein and it can have multiple
BIOS sequences but then there's a higher
level of structural organization that
goes beyond just the sequences because
you have to say how the thing arranges
that's right you could have a structure
in protein databank that to make that
structure you need multiple sequences I
have to say that I don't think I mean I
think that we're going to need
eventually something okay so there's a
question also for the chemistry folk
right so you've got things which are
molecules okay more naive questions um
you know you got a molecule it's a
covalently bonded thing and it hangs out
with you know through some I don't know
hydrogen bonding I don't know what some
weaker bonding thing it's a it's a
cluster of stuff woody how do you
represent that how are we imagining
representing clusters
question four adjacent right so uh so
right now we don't have any non-covalent
bonds I we've talked about using having
a hydrogen bond and other types of bonds
but as far as a cluster of of molecules
weakly bound together we don't have any
any design for that
okay so science question in these things
like these you know these multimers in
the in the bio case what is the binding
between the different proteins
I should know that but I can't tell you
okay we're talking about magnitude of
strength og what's the type of bond that
that's holding them together because
they're not covalent okay okay so the
protein itself is held together
covalently but when they when they form
these these these multimers they don't
um those are just some different kind of
bonding is that right I think you guys
are looking for a quick tour and airy
structure there
that's right yeah we have the problem
too and even when you have two nuclei
gasses just Tibor dyes watson-crick
paired to each other versus one you have
to represent them as different things
for us so we waited it all by the
structure which is a higher level join
of I guess a bio sequence in a bio
sequence bound to each other okay that's
what that's what I was guessing we're
gonna have to do too
so I mean you know so it becomes
something like a bio structure which has
which contains bio sequences if-if-if
bio sequence contains the structural
nesting on the on the inside and can
represent can represent multiple
multiple sequences then all of the
existing functions for that operate on
bio sequences don't necessarily need to
be redefined we had that I guess an
earlier design that we didn't quite
figure out all the details of which
would say that you have by a sequence
contains multiple bio sequences and then
there's some meta information with let
me ask a simple question okay so we've
got some RNA and we actually can figure
out the tertiary you know the spatial
layout of the RNA probably I don't know
I go that's that's decently doable yes
and so now in our bio sequence a little
bit like in the molecule case write a
molecule could just be the the kind of
you know chemical structure but it could
also have the spatial information does
bio sequence also in your design allow
some specification of spatial
information yes there's a lot of room
for from for meta information and
additional options to specify so extreme
okay so what you're saying is so okay
whatever we do here should be similar
between molecule and bio sequence for
dealing with these cluster II type
things so in other words if molecule is
going to have multiple sort of chemical
units inside it and you know cuz
presumably with a molecule
you know if we have some cluster it's
specified by you know coordinates of
things in the different what's the
difference I mean yeah well
have it okay in the case of molecule do
we have a current thought for how we're
going to handle the like even they are
like bonded things what are we doing for
ionically bonded things
so look let's see so the the 3d
structures we come up with it for with
with ionically bonded is they're not
they're not see they're not good right
so we just lay each out each each piece
I know it's a big mess because you can
have a crystal and I don't know how we
represent the Crystal Freight I mean so
I was with crystals or whatnot I
envisioned some some different head like
some type of a unit cell type of
function
alright let's ignore the infinitely
repeating ones because that's and
presumably and okay naive question like
it in the in the lipid bilayer thing of
a cell do you have okay in biology do
you have infinitely repeating things
like that are they relevant or is it
only these these information carrying
sequences that anybody cares about
for this project we've really only
attended to the information carrying
ones but there are certainly infinitely
repeating you know structures that are
of concern for likely safer
okay the bilayers and then what about
lipids what about in the case of
ordering molecules when we have polymers
like you know PVC or something or some
other I don't know either
other polymers that are considered in
flip infinite for purposes of chemistry
or is it always so it's a you know it's
some specific length hydrocarbon or
something no I mean you can definitely
can for all intents and purposes
consider them infinite and I always
imagined that we would we would have
work our way around having a
macromolecule head that would though it
allow us some type of in-between
representation halfway between the all
atom case and the bio sequence case okay
yeah okay anyway so one thing we clearly
got to think about is how to deal with
this you know additional cluster type
stuff for both the bio sequence case and
the molecule case
not to throw in complexity but you've
got to deal with some nonlinear stuff
too like if you get to carbohydrates you
have to deal with branching and that
sort of thing in the bio sequence space
that's macromolecule but similar problem
yep
yes and I mean clearly with our ordinary
molecule we deal with that with having a
graph an underlying graph to represent
where the component how the components
are connected to each other
um but is that not scalable to the macro
molecule case or is that still you know
is it what you would do is to represent
and think this was similar to what you
were saying about multiple bio sequences
where you have each stretch each linear
chain stretch is one thing and then
you're basically just saying this is how
those linear chains are connected
together here's the graph of how they're
connected is that a reasonable way to
think about it that's definitely how I
think about the the macro molecule so
you define each each individual unit and
whatever hairs it has coming off of it
and then then you construct the graph
from those and if you have repeating
units then you are saving space by by
doing it this way right Brian does that
seem reasonable to you based on what
you've seen with these sort of more
exotic carbohydrates and so on yeah
definitely in fact if you want to look
up good precedence there you should look
up the representations people use
especially in the carbohydrate databases
and that sort of thing because they have
to handle the branch structure as a
regular thing and you don't want to draw
the full atomic structure out for
something like that when you're just
saying it's this branch did this sugar
at this position okay science question
how many times does how many how many
levels are branching are relevant and
your average you know what we eat
carbohydrate type thing this is like one
or two or is it like many excellent
question I know think it's that crazy I
think it's less than double digits yeah
yeah five or six and what what's the
thing you in what's the example just I
guess if you had a glycoprotein you
might have change sticking off the end
of a protein by the way that then goes
into the carbohydrate that itself might
have something like five levels of
branching not much more than that fair
enough okay
functionality oh my gosh there's a lot
of stuff here
yeah I mean I don't know whether this
representation
I mean I've you know in my little
adventures with my own genome and so on
I mean this representation is not
horrible I don't know whether given that
we're taking this stuff more seriously
now whether we should think about okay
the real question is when you're gonna
use the thing is this representation
useful right so it's like like you could
imagine like you know one of our very
early successful sort of kind of more
implicit representations was
interpolating function question is when
you use one of these sequence alignments
how do you use it what do you do what
operations do do on the sequence
alignment
so usually when I work with sequence
alignments it comes out of something
like muscle or or math or whatever and
there I get a FASTA file that is just
going to be string of the reference
string of entity one string of entity
two extremes of entity three and each
string will have dashes inserted into it
and so now the total now they total the
same length and I can now just do simple
four loops and so forth and work through
them where if I want to work with column
one I can just iterate through column
one column two and then look at
diversity and be able to work with that
yeah so one thing that you're saying is
that we need an operation that will take
after sequence alignment has been done
that will take something like this and
return the the individual strings with
dashes to represent where like like in
this case here I mean it's not totally
obvious to me that there isn't
necessarily unique place to put the
dashes is that true or is there always
if it's a deletion yeah I guess there is
is that true for this more than two yeah
there might be there will be for this
particular alignment there will be
particular batching support there could
always do alignment I search saying
right it's the minimal diff the
alignment represents the diffs
effectively and the diffs might not be
unique that is the right okay but so one
thing that's clearly useful I can see
why that will be useful is to just take
something where you you know you turn
this into a thing do we do we have that
operation John of turning this into
something with you know equal length
strings with dashes in them we don't
have that but that that's great that'll
handle multiple sequence alignment a lot
better and look at that okay all right
let's just um oh my gosh okay I'm gonna
open a bunch of these just because we're
running out of time and I want to see
what's here okay okay that's pretty
straightforward
yeah I mean the challenge here is are we
doing this with with sub value
properties or are we doing it with
functions and I kind of agree that we
should have some functions I mean it
just scares me when I see that number of
functions it's a small network because
you do something on the sink it's not
you have to make something out of it no
I agree I agree
okay obviously the transcription target
I mean I would say this transcribe' is
specific I mean what about from RNA to
protein is that a oh that's that's
translation fair enough
you
that's a can of worms isn't it oh my
gosh
so okay fair enough offsets and frame
adjustments oh my gosh what a can of
worms okay so that's essentially this is
analogous to when we do binary read list
I mean it's kind of outrageous but it
has to be that way you know this thing
about read to a terminator and so on
right here we're reading to a start
codon or okay so we already have a
syntactic mechanism I don't know how
good it is for like reading to a newline
and so on um and we probably should look
at that to see how that corresponds to
this I I doubt that we're gonna want
this whole I mean given that there's a
very specific function by our sequence
translate I don't see why we need an
option here to say start codon that's
that's more like an argument here oh
yeah yeah that's that's that's fair that
the one the one thing that's tricky
about that is is that these options also
apply to the inverse translation and the
inverse translation you you can either
take a sample with a single argument or
you can have all translations by adding
all as a second argument so which which
argument there will be some design to
fit yeah okay fair enough today okay
fine um okay what is this genetic
translation table oh I see that's oh boy
that's this business right okay and how
many different how many different cases
how many different standards
I wouldn't say ISO standards but how
many different how many standards does
the evolution come up with wow this
translation works
they're about thirty standard
standardized ones well
exotic amino acids that exist only and
you know just of particular translations
the codons are standard the amino acids
are or standard here and then it's just
different different kind of degeneracy
one master but so when you have a
degenerate sequence genome sequence what
happens when you say translation does it
I mean how can it know what to do so it
will that's why I guess but things have
the option of either one or all and why
this is and I guess an option here so if
you just say translate it picks you an
arbitrary one if you say all it will
give you back a list of all of them a
little bit messy I mean that's the
difference between replace and replace
list so to speak I mean in other words
is it is it just a single yeah okay oh
boy okay so these are to see two
sequences and this is finding the
degenerate sequence that covers both of
them let's have a quick look ahead here
so these are things weed this entire
section are things we don't include but
are just considerations for future
functionality
that's an interesting issue because
obviously you can't do comparisons if
you've put you your IDs in the middle of
things on the other hand there may be
cases and emerald folk probably have
opinions about this there may be cases
where it is really good to have I mean
or the question is the UUID might be in
an outer layer that I'm you know I'm
sure emerald has you you IDs for
everything you're probably not down at
this level um in other words you you
have a rapper you have a container you
know a um that has a UUID but it's not
clear the thing that is contained has to
have its own burnt in UUID do you have
an opinion about that we have a cyst
constellation which is our database
looks a lot like the entity system but
with fixed ontology is for everything so
you just type type it as you know this
is a what's an example like just like BM
IV on we have IDs for all of our objects
so like a piece of analysis you did as
an ID this is a strand model fair enough
right so everything that goes into your
database has an ID yes right for us to
travels right so you could put it into
the DNA synthesizer and say go make this
thing and it knows that without having
to transmit everything along with it
yeah I understand I understand but it's
exactly kind of what I was saying that
the rapper contains the ID rather than
the rappy so to speak containing the ID
oh yes
I kind of think that our rappy should
not contain the ID any more than the
number thirteen contains an ID so to
speak you know in other words you just
do whatever you do with 13 but if it
needed to be wrapped then that'll be my
initial take the case of that was is for
are things like the short read mapping
where you have a large number of very
small reads coming up and you're mapping
them to specific genetic features and at
the end of the analysis one analysis
comes back that's the entire alignment
and you want to see okay where did each
of these reads end up and so it might
not be more of a different that's a
different issue that's a different issue
I mean that's that's kind of the issue
that we're seeing in I don't know
something like face recognition of
something well you've got
image and it's like these are the faces
in the image okay where did where are
those faces in the image and things like
that straight and that that we've got
different patterns for dealing with but
I have a question with respect to the
actual processing of of data I mean to
what extent are we going to be in a
position if people have fancy
special-purpose
I don't even know these days what is
what is the you know surely there's GPU
code for dealing with sequencing
alignment what will be our story in
terms of being able to make use of that
or is it not the case I mean I would
think that was a is isn't I mean I don't
really know what the what what is the
state of the art these days for I mean
you know I use math for most of my
sequence alignment it's not it's it's
not cheap you enabled but it does handle
things pretty pretty well and yeah we
talked about this I talked about this
John previously basically we're the way
that most the stuff what happens now is
use things like snake make and next flow
to string together a lot of different
scripts and like some of those might be
our own scripts and some of those might
be running math and running other things
and then would I picture a lot of this
being useful is being will quickly you
want to do I owe to kind of pull things
into it from FASTA or from whatever
format it is process something within
within more from and then then be able
to export an artifact that can then me
kind of insert it into that into our
data flows and then the question is what
formats to those existing data flows eat
um so the for what we do faster and VCF
and those are long-running formats I
mean those happen all the time
exactly okay and all the new ones that
are sort of the main the main new ones
that are new within that's maybe 10
years or things like BAM which are just
designed to be shorter ways to represent
loss of genetic data so you don't
represent all the sequences in study of
a reference and you just say what's
changed first is the reference
fair enough hum okay so this is these
are things for machine learning basis
for okay and this whole business about
visualization which seems important to
have some generic you know to have some
standard collection of bio sequence
visualizing tools I mean that's right
but I mean is it the case
I mean look in my own little efforts
poking around in my own genome you know
I have never used these interactive sort
of exploration things they're very cool
but they're not very useful to me at
least looking for particular things what
is that what is the typical experience I
mean these these things which are sort
of genome
hello genome explorers that a very
interactive are they are they viewed as
being um highly desirable or not I know
that Isabelle's made a fair in her lab
work has made a fair use of particularly
circular views where she's trying to
discern German you know where to insert
things and plasmids and things and
things like this but it's really good
for things that was small on play
usually yes but I'm asking like the
human genome viewers where you're doing
the giant zoom from infinity and right
is that useful or is that just a toy I
for me that's like a toy but the kind of
corollary where you actually
experimental data from RNA seek or some
other sequencing experiments that they
don't very commonly just getting that
lead stack where you can kind of see the
reference and you see how you you're a
million reads stack onto it and you can
kind of have the very zoomed out view
where you just kind of get a little like
clonal sparkline little kind of you see
where in the genomes hit you can zoom in
and see like oh we're getting snips in
this
that that is the most common right I
mean we haven't even discussed that the
question of the actual stack of reeds
and you know we're talking here about
consensus genomes aren't we and you know
there's a question because that seems
like a useful thing that people actually
care about is because you you know one
of those things was it was an
undetermined base you actually care what
the stack of reads at that position was
is that true that's right I I really
have to run unfortunately um the I wish
we could have gone on with this and
another time we should we should stretch
it out for longer this is a this is a
lot of stuff to go through
um this is very helpful as an
introduction this looks quite wonderful
and this is gonna be a great system um I
just
it's it needs work we knew that um so um
um we only came to this point by doing
over the affair might've work yes I can
see that right but this is yeah um
nozzle to our meeting let's let's do a
two-hour meeting yeah
with as many people from here as can
attend okay wonderful
okay well thank you all very much and
thanks this is looking looking looking
wonderful all right I gotta run
unfortunately see you soon thanks have a
great day